si je vais chez le psy ça va être encore
pire non mais si je vais chez le psy ça
va me faire remonter des trucs là à la
surface soit ça va me mettre mal soit ça
va me rendre fou carrément donc NON NON
MERCI aller chez une psy ou chez un psy
ça ne réveille pas des maladies et si ça
soulève quelque chose qui vous fait du
mal c'est quelque chose que vous avez en
vous de toute façon et qui serait
ressorti à un moment ou à un autre donc
bah il vaut mieux faire ça bien avec une
professionnelle ou avec un professionnel
et le plutôt c'est le mieux on va faire
une comparaison imaginez que vous allez
chez le dentiste et il vous trouve une
petite infection à une dent vous vous
aviez rien vu vous aviez rien senti ça
faisait pas encore mal et pourtant
c'était déjà là le dentiste il va
soigner votre infection et sur le coup
c'est possible que ce soit plus ou moins
douloureux mais on est d'accord que
c'est pas une raison pour pas aller chez
le dentiste parce que ça évite que ça
s'aggrave là-dedans et que ça finisse en
abscès ou en rche de dents et ben chez
le psy c'est pareil et puis la vérité
c'est que la plupart du temps ça fait
pas du mal d'aller chez le psy ça fait
même plutôt du bien ça soulage